theo what up brendan i got a king
interesting it for you
uh cruises that water vacation king
anderson
gang gang buzz buzz buzz buzz
girl i just got invited on the
impractical jokers cruise next year
god be such a hard pass for me really
yeah
these guys are awesome i mean their fans
are awesome no they're great
stuck on a cruise with anyone yeah be a
nightmare
you're talking about a buffet of the sea
you're talking about a hotel i
can't leave and i'm trapped in the
middle of the [ __ ] ocean but you're
trapped with everything you want
not really i want to get away well you
can do that but you have to just come
right back
gambling they have gambling they have
all types of soda
they have free meals all day and night
entertainment
what else pool a hard pass for me dude
i don't want to be part of it though
you're on the beach you basically live
on the beach you are
you're you're your own beach but you're
stuck on this cruise ship
but you can walk around where you're not
chained to something
you know you can meet other people you
can put sunglasses on
that's a good point you know you can put
you can be outside
you're gonna start touring get fish off
the back are you gonna start touring on
cruises
what's next you and kid rock doing a
live tour together
kid rock's a legend bro he is he and he
does cruises you know that does he
oh yeah there's a kid rock cruise uh
gronkowski did a cruise last year
really yeah the gronkowski the grunt
crew i bet there were no stds going on
during that i mean but who all who goes
on that thing a lot of just pats fans
probably
i have no idea i have no i i don't know
anyone that goes on cruises
it's a hard pass for me dude really oh
it's a nightmare mike i think it i i
think
that cruises are nice i think have you
been on one yeah i went when i was
little i hated it man
dude i went on this thing called
semester at sea where you were on a
cruise for 100 days
you're on a cruise ship i always
wondered what kids went on semester
at sea you went on it yeah interesting
you go to school on there
um and it was experiencing fun like you
they stop at all the ports
stop at all the like a lot of different
countries check it out
it was awesome was it cool how old were
you when you did that
let me see i was 21.
okay i thought you were a little younger
really
yeah i thought you were younger that was
cool dude
not as cool i thought you were like 14.
oh okay wow so you basically went on
vacation
it is like vacation but i think four or
five days cruise i like it man you get a
lot of pineapple on there they got the
buffet
i don't like you know i do i would do
one section of the buffet at a time so
you don't
blow it all in one meal you know i would
take it easy dude bad
food and these days the cruises didn't
see the one cruise that just got [ __ ]
tipped over
you're always flying all over the
goddamn place some lady jumped off and
they never
found her [ __ ] that dude now somebody is
always trying to kill their wife these
days yeah but i go she just fell over
yeah
so at night you got like 60 guys up
there trying to get their wife to you
know
take a picture on the rail you know
let's
let's recreate titanic babe yeah fall
over the front also i've seen titanic
way too many times to jump on a giant
cruise ship
yeah you could also just watch titanic
and get a couple cans of dole at the
house
that's true dude so i think that's one
way it's a hard
uh sting for me um i usually king
everything
i can do a three night cruise i don't
think i could do anything
more than that
[Music]
is